It's an honor and pleasure for me to be
part of this Islamic
part of Lancawi Islamic International
Conference 2025. The theme of which is
Islamic
sustainable development goals.
And as some of us may be aware that in
the United Nations
they got together
and
they had a meeting and they decided on
17 sustainable development goals to
improve this world. So they had a plan
of 15 years that by 2030 they will
improve this whole world for humankind
and they pointed out 17 sustainable
goals.
So this conference is held the first
time
on the theme Islamic
sustainable development goals
and what United Nation had discussed
alhamdulillah has already been mentioned
by Allah subhanana wa ta'ala in the
glorious Quran and in the sayings of our
beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the authentic a hadith.
So in this conference
we have mashallah 17 speakers and each
one of them will speak on one
sustainable goal and what Islam what
Quran what had to say about it
and I'll be speaking on the fifth
sustainable development goals as per the
United Nations that is gender equality
and the topic of of my talk is
true and practical
true and practical gender equality and
Islamic solution.
I would like to repeat the topic of this
talk of mine is true and practical
gender equality and Islamic solution.
Before we start,
let me ask you a question here.
Since
feminism is related to this topic of
gender equality, who amongst here
agrees and believes in feminism? Please
raise your hand.
Mashallah. Not a single one of you
or except for my wife, my
daughter-in-law. That's cheating. Huh?
They have got inside information.
I could see two or three hand among the
ladies. Not a single one of you believes
in feminism. Now let me give you the
definition of feminism and then I'll ask
you whether you believe in feminism or
not. According to Oxford dictionary,
feminism means a belief and aim
that
the belief and aim in women's rights
and opportunities as equal to men.
Oxford dictionary says that feminism
means a belief and aim that women's
rights
and opportunities will be the same as
men.
Feminist is a person who believes that
men and women should have equal rights.
Who believes in feminism?
Who believes in feminism? Raise your
hand.
Feminism means men and women should have
equal rights.
Okay. 10%.
Raise your hand. Who believe that men
and women should have equal rights?
Raise your hand.
Mashallah. Almost all. Almost all men
and women. Male and female. Both.
Does Islam believe that men and women
are equal?
Does Islam believe men and women are
equal? Raise your hand. Yes or no? Yes.
Who says yes? Does Islam believe that
men and women are equal?
Inshallah we'll discuss this topic and
we'll come to know. So according to me
the word feminism is a misnomer.
Initially
when this word was first used in 1851
by definition as of now
as of now by the true definition of
feminism as of now I am a feminist
Dr. Zaki Nike is a feminist Islam
believes in feminism as of now.
But if you go back to history
in 1851,
this word when it was used the first
time, it meant being more feminine.
Feminism when was used the first time in
1851.
It meant being more feminine
and had a little bit of a matriarchal
that we know that that woman is a little
bit more superior.
And today what we find in the western
world when people who mainly talk about
feminism they have that little bit of
aura that you know women are superior.
In this context I'm not a feminist but
truly if you go by the definition what
it literally means it means that men and
women have equal rights.
So therefore I call feminism as a
misnomer.
If I go out and say that Zak is a
feminist, people will think okay he's
trying to say that women are more
superior than men.